it's been a while since we spoke last
time but I haven't been rested I've been
busy I've been busy because now we are
working on an indicator uh it's gonna
it's gonna be called
indicators when I have the week for the
strategy liquidity pools the trading
sessions and it's gonna make everything
so much easier for us
um I don't know how long it's gonna take
us but we've already started working on
that to develop it and we are very
excited so if you want to hear more
about this then you can go to Twitter
where I posted some tweets about this
topic
and also talking about Twitter I guess
that most of you follow me on Twitter
and you've seen the Bitcoin Sunday
update this is an update that I do every
Sunday for the past year and a half and
the goal of this bit concerned updates
is to prepare ourselves ahead for the
week okay this was a projection that we
had in in the last bit when uh Sunday
update and basically we were talking
about the idea that we didn't like
all of these projections of the 50ma
what lost it's not that we didn't like
is that we found it suspicious okay
because if you notice
do you get I don't know how many times
we tested the 50 EMA in the photos time
frame as resistance but many times and
there was not really a sell-off because
if you notice this Zone
is some kind of a range okay
we haven't we haven't really lost this
one right it's I mean it's kind of
sideways so there was not a sell-off
like this all right and in fact you can
also see this week to the upside
all right so we were talking about the
idea of one more short squeeze okay for
this you also want to think about the
timing because I always said it's
pointless if I give you targets but I
won't give you the timing okay timing is
very important and it's possible to time
the market is difficult for sure but
this thing guys that it's possible and
only me I'm sure they're over traders
that can't time the market pretty
decently okay now the idea behind this
prediction was to see uh Monday's first
move to the downside all right why this
target well because you had here two
weeks you have this week and also this
week so remember that the boys have to
get filled at least 50 percent of them
but you can see that the full week
of this one
it's very close to the 50 percent of
this week so we were projecting the idea
of among this false move
below here okay so then you can remove
this week
and this week too and then you can see a
reaction to the upside okay now
obviously here what you want to see is
then
Bitcoin going above the fifth domain
testing as resist a support sorry and
then continue going higher where to well
you have this week to the upside okay
that's uh thirty thousand and then on
Thursday probably because we have the
CPI data I think it's Gonna Come
hot okay I really think that we want to
see a spike up in the CPI and that could
bring some kind of midweek reversal okay
where to well this line over here this
white line do you know what this is guys
those are the range lows right so if we
close again another candle
well a daily candle or or even more
important another weekly candle below
the range lows that's not good okay but
in the moment that we start to see a
daily candle and even more important a
weekly candle close enough of the rain
slows
okay then you can expect more upside so
to me really
the question is again
are we gonna close the weekly above the
range lows or below the range lose again
and that's going to be quite important
for the next week all right it's kind of
like a cycle so let's see how this is
how this has played out right so let me
remove this
and let's have a look at the chart
okay what are the photos time frame and
there you go
okay this week gets filled the 50 of the
week gets filled perfect almost to the
dollar
uh that was a 28 699
I think let me check
no actually 28 701 right I'm a long
order was at twenty thousand seven
hundred thirty so that was a very good
entry and now you can see price has
reacted from this zone I'm pushed away
from this Zone Gob of the 4r50ma tested
a support and now another green candle
okay so yep when you see this Scandal
closing above the 15 minute four or time
frame then you're going to see the next
candles testing as a support as you can
see here and this is even more important
because another song Traders might see
this candle as a very Scandal but
inner trading system this scandal in
this context is not bearish why because
it's testing the 4r50 made that has been
resistance all this time
and also because it left quite a long
week behind so the this is telling you
that okay we found support and there is
also an efficiency to the upside okay
and this is uh 200 move so that would be
a nice scalp all right now today is
Tuesday if I'm not yeah today is Tuesday
I don't even know what day is today this
today is this day before the Monday is
for smooth and the work strength should
be to the upside okay how long can this
last
Wednesday or Thursday I'm gonna say
Thursday
because the CPI data could bring a
midweek reversal okay but we could
finish tomorrow I think that today
I'm not favoring the idea to see price
dumping below the 450 I mean again okay
if that happened then I would cut my
long okay and I will be looking for the
next trade I will have to go again
through the chart because that would
invalidate the projection of the
Bitcoins on the update I hope that's
clear guys now the most likely thing is
that price either continuous pushing
higher and test the range lows they're
gonna find some resistance there you can
see
all right and then if we get above it
you wanted to test it out support
not like what happened here maybe for
you this is a test of support
but to me no because again you have a
long week
there so it's likely the price dumps
again to fail long week okay so what you
want to see something like what you've
seen here all right but you want to see
that
above the range slow second and that
will tell you okay you know we've got
the range lows
to fill the 50 of this week at least
right and then it's when Thursday
probably can come to meet with reversal
so that's my plan for the week guys all
right now let me remove this
okay I'm gonna remove uh the 50 of the
week and also this week over here I'm
Gonna Leave This a hundred percent of
the week because
even though price fails the 50 of the
week at least then we consider that this
week has been filled okay we also have
scenario a reaction but this is also the
actual law right so that's gonna be also
quite important level in the chart
because now you can imagine that anybody
that is going along even if you see some
kind of retricia
anybody that is going along they're
gonna place the stop losses here
and also here right so that's what I'm
doing also that week because I know that
in this Zone
that I'm marking in this one over here I
know there is quality of liquidity still
all right now the question is when are
they going to hone this liquidity
because don't get me wrong if I go into
the daily time frame I still I still
think that it's very likely
the price can come back down and test
you know this potential support
um
if I'm honest with you either I do think
that in the next say 36 months is very
likely that we see Bitcoin coming lower
probably retracing this liquidity pools
over here okay that's what I think in
the higher time frame I think that
you're more interested in the in the
lower time frame uh most of you now the
question is before this happens
because again I think that we're gonna
come and fill these liquidity pools
before that happens is it possible that
Bitcoin has
another push higher
that's a good point isn't it guys so let
me go to the four hour time frame
first of all
I'll tell you what I think I think that
we're gonna probably fill this this week
over here but you can for example fill
this week on a Wednesday and then you
can boom and close the weekly candle
again below the range looks which is the
main resistance so let's see how the
balls both if we see a quickly candle
closing above the range lows right so
imagine you see something like this and
you see how quickly candle closing above
here
then that is telling me or probably with
a daily candle let me check the daily
time frame well not really because then
you want to see the next one holding a
support okay you don't want to see what
happened here
check it out okay so let's go back to
the photos
so if we see Bitcoin
getting above the range lows testing of
support then I want a favorite idea that
we're gonna see
price pushing towards the mid-range the
price gets above the mid-range then it's
gonna go again to the Rain size if he
breaks Above This Zone with enough
volume then they're gonna see another
Spike higher
to 32k I assume that there is also some
liquidity up there so I cannot dismiss
the idea
we're gonna go
support by support resistance by
resistance and for now
I'm gonna continue betting on the I
don't know what is it on the projection
I want the projection back
where is my prediction
uh I'm gonna continue betting
on the Sunday Bitcoin update in this
projection right so I'm gonna go step by
step
but if we get back
above the range lows we hold this Zone
then you're gonna see another leg up to
the mid range hold above here another
leg up okay break above here with
noticeable volume because this breakout
all right this breakout here had no
volume so it was clear they was gonna
roll over again do you want to see a
breakout with volume
check this out yesterday the volume
daily time frame
sorry look at this
this candle
is your Breakout
this one here
that's ridiculous guys because you had
even more volume
here
and here and also here this over here
has no volume to break through all right
so do you want to see
a breakout with a spike
at least
the size okay that's what you want to
see otherwise that's not enough volume
you want to see a breakout also in
volume to tell you that that's actually
not a false move right so um that's what
I meant
is it possible that we get there is
definitely possible but again
we're gonna go step by step okay do you
still have here
resistance right then you won't decide
to hold the support if you can break
through
okay hola support and then we'll come
talk about the mid-range get back above
the mid range then we're going to talk
about the range highs break with volume
and we're going to talk about you know
32k so that's what I think but again
in a higher time frame
I think they want to come lower
I think I'm Gonna Come to be honest is
still low okay I'm not talking about new
lows
I'm just talking
about these inefficiencies
over here
and these are around 22k
21k
even 20K all right that's at least one
target now of course again if you come
here and you break below this
is
this area here is later that I'm
targeting for the next say three six
nine months
um just before the bull market that's
what it is what I think usually also
do you guys know the
the second half of every pre-halving
year and that's this year because next
year we have the halving the second half
of the pre-half India is usually bearish
well always it's always very so
um that's also a reason why uh looking
at the cycle
to kind of tell you this time is going
to be different I'm not the kind of a
guy okay so um that's what I think now I
hope that's clear for Bitcoin let's talk
about ethereum because the idea of the
Bitcoin soon to update was also thanks
to the ethereum Chart check this out
because we were thinking that ethereum
was living
the market right so let me get the
weekly 50ma
there you go all right this one of
course is a support level check this out
you got here one head over here you got
many many hits all right so always we
always say the same thing by the way
this is not my chart
this is my chart I think yeah that's my
chart uh this was the projection from
the Sunday update and we were talking
about there is huge liquidity below this
support because you have longer stop
losses everybody that was longing inside
this Zone had the rest stop losses
around this one all right so a spike
down with a wig
were actually then tested but we were
two dollars away
right
it would stop all those longer positions
and then they can reverse price
okay
and the market make it is
because all the Longs have been stopped
so nobody's gonna take his money all
right also not only for the longest stop
losses but if you break through this
level imagine all the Bears thinking oh
we broke below support let's go and
Trigger that short position
okay they've interrupt or liquidated
during Wars right so that was the logic
behind this trade there you go if you go
into the one our time frame
he created a week
you can see but then that week was
filled straight away with the next
candle
okay it felt at least 50 percent of that
week so
price can go up and we don't consider
this an inefficiency or an imbalance
okay so it's not looking bad to be
honest guys I tell you that of course
I'm a bit nervous about CPI because that
can't change
pretty much everything book
my logic tells me that and so far is
correct Force move at the start of the
week and then
a pump
before the CPI data and then maybe a
reversal after CPI okay that's what I
think that's what I think guys uh so
let's go now to hybrid Capital let's
check out those liquidations
and see if they can give us any more
clues
why don't you have low Capital let's
check how the liquidation levels
oh come on
all right there you go
velta pretty much back to zero one
billion a half worth of lungs and the
peak of short liquidations was at
around three no I think it was around
five before but then this consolidation
has
a kind of research okay
this is 269 total liquid long
liquidations
this is telling me that
the the the Traders are not decided
whether this is gonna go up or down and
usually when price goes up like it's
been going up now
did you see more long liquidations we do
we do but if you notice the difference
is quite small but it's telling me that
there is still a call of people trying
to short this move so that could fill
this move to go even higher why not look
at this Zone this is Spike at the
highest 29
958 you know what sun is guys that's the
week
that's the week so that's your logic
behind also Target industry okay this is
some kind of Confluence the uh you can
use in hablo Capital now let's go to the
liquidation hit map
let's check this out seven days time
frame
what do I see here
wow
loads of liquidity everywhere well
between two liquidation Zone
28 600 actually I didn't notice this by
Squad queries that we didn't come and
hit this this this this Zone over here
okay so I'll be leaving this one for
later on
might be uh but also at highs three
thirty thousand one hundred
right above the the week
which makes sense you know right above
those previous highs
um quite interesting
I think both of these ones are gonna get
hit
but
if we hit thirty thousand one hundred
first then you need to see price dumping
and closing below the range loss that
the Rangers I think they are around this
Zone 29 500 600 I think it is okay then
you want to see price dumping and
closing the weekly Bill below this Zone
and then it could tell you that the
start of the next week the condom price
to watch this Zone again 28 600 okay
otherwise if you pump from here hit
these liquidations and close the weekly
above the range lows
this song can't wait for some more time
all right
let's go to the monthly time frame
monetary time frame
no hang on I don't think
that was good
that's better
okay
um thirty thousand two hundred
again we sell off into the dealer and
also we can see a lot of 32k all right
somewhere liquidity I put in over there
which means that everybody is trying to
show this market right now all right so
again that could fuel
some kind
so again that could Fuel and move higher
that's also the idea why we can't
dismiss but once more we have the range
losses resistance we're gonna have the
mid range so you want to see price
getting above those zones and holding
the mass support to even consider the
video that 32k is possible
all right but this is telling you that
the market is shorting why because price
has been consolidating
below resistance so everybody is trying
to Short
but also when that happens for such a
long time like it's happening now and
you don't see a sell-off
that is telling you that Bitcoin is so
in some timed of a strength because
otherwise it would just dump all the way
down so
um
quite interesting I think that we're
gonna see
if maybe 30 200 getting filled anytime
soon
also of course you have 28 200
um one twenty thousand one hundred
that's basically the potential support
that we showed in the chart the previous
range so a lot of liquidity difficult to
make any sense of this because uh we
just have to wait and see if we can get
back above some resistances right and
then in the three months time frame
24 000 okay that's the only yellow bar
000.
all right six months time frame I
haven't looked at this one for quite
some time
wow 24 000 and lower although to twenty
one thousand five hundred ish
and some liquidity bar less you can see
above after the above 32k all right so
again
I think that
in the short term we want to fill the
week that it's at 29 900.
okay
then
their weekly candle close is going to
decide what's going to happen next
if we see that pump that I just
mentioned uh almost to 30k and then we
close
the weekly candle above the range lows
we can have higher targets for example
the mid range that will be the next
Target but if we see this poem to 30k
and then it dumps with the midweek
reversal and we close the weekly candle
below the range lows
then we might have just witnessed the
last shorter squeeze and then we're
gonna go lower and for the midterm
get above the mid-range and we're gonna
start to think about 32k
all right
otherwise price is gonna dump and
the higher time frame Theory might play
when in the midterm and that's a drop
quite an aggressive drop to 24
22 21k
okay below 25k and we basically between
25 and 20k that's at least
a drop that I'm uh I'm waiting for okay
and that should line up also with uh the
Bitcoin dominance
holding I'm not jumping with Bitcoin and
the total three going down so that's
when you could for example buy some
algorithms all right that's uh my logic
again no Financial advice
I just told you pretty quickly
what happened in my head those are my my
thoughts let's see how this evolves
someplace else but for now as Traders I
think that by the way let me tell you
again I think this Market
at least at the moment it's still a
Trader's Market a non-investor's market
maybe this age is bad
um in some months I regret okay but I do
think that at least in my under my
opinion I think that this is a Trader's
Market at least for the next three to
six months and then when we see the SMP
coming down between coming down
um I don't think the outcomes are gonna
really get wrecked then that's when I'm
gonna say this is now an investors
Market let's pick up small Queens right
well again I might regret it's my age
but let's see what happens all right so
thank you so much for watching
and I'll see you soon